we live in a capitalist World therefore
we need to put a price on nature because
that is when unfortunately people start
to Value it species a is worth 50 bucks
and species B is worth ten thousand
dollars it's like going to a grocery
store
[Music]
Barnabas is declining in such a rapid
rate around 25 of plant and animal
species are close to extinction I find
that terrifying
[Music]
foreign
causes of the loss of wild nature are
complex but what is driving the biggest
changes today is capitalism
[Music]
one solution to this problem is to Value
nature to put a price on it because
unfortunately in the world we live in
once something has a value to it people
are less likely to destroy it can these
very tools that drive the decline of
nature be the tools that help us reverse
the process
humans emerged from nature were part of
the biosphere it feeds us it clothes us
it cleans out air it provides us with
fresh water it is really important for
our physical and mental well-being
I think it's useful to think about an
ecosystem and whether an ecosystem
destroyed or harvested is worth more or
less than an ecosystem intact in many
cases there is more value in that
ecosystem and the challenge is to
recognize that value
one of the really big issues I think
with value in nature is how do you do it
[Music]
when you cut down a tree and you sell it
as Timber you're able to realize the
market value of that Timber whereas if
that tree Still Remains in a forest it's
playing a lot of functional roles for
surrounding communities and even the
global Community
plants one really interesting question
is how much is the Amazon rainforest
worth how does it compare to Amazon the
company the question has an obvious
answer the Amazon rainforest is the
center of biodiversity on planet Earth
there's no way that is worth less than a
company
[Music]
so if we started for example by looking
at the carbon value in terms of climate
change mitigation rainfall that's being
generated by that rainforest existing
the biodiversity that provides lots of
interactions around pollination and
controlling pests that may one day
provide medical benefits for people and
on top of that that rainforest is
ancient it's been around for 60 million
years and that has intrinsic respect and
value that we also need to consider in
the equation
viewing nature as an asset rather than a
commodity is absolutely essential
because an asset you always want to
build on you want to enhance and you
want to protect
thank you
[Music]
one of the big arguments is that it
doesn't recognize the intrinsic
relationships that people have with
nature we get senses of identity sense
of place cultural relationships and
rituals and none of those can be
properly represented with monetary
evaluation you cannot depend upon
pricing of natural as the solution to
problems because we cannot price the
price list
I mean the danger with putting a price
on nature is that you create incentives
for people to cheapen nature because
they want to make money off of it
communities that live close to Nature
and are dependent on nature directly are
often the poorest as a consequence given
their low incomes the economic value of
what they get from nature the positive
benefits that they get turns out to be
very low we do not want to price out
those who have very low incomes living
close to nature but in poverty and
therefore eliminating their voices from
the decision-making system
foreign
[Music]
if you're a developer you want to build
a bunch of houses you know that your new
housing complex is going to kill off
breathing pairs of burrowing owls you
need to account for those burrowing owls
someplace else and so you have to then
say I'm willing to pay two thousand
dollars for a burring owl who out there
can conserve a burrowing out for two
thousand dollars for me because that's
the budget that I have it's like going
to a grocery store
one of the pioneering examples of
bringing nature to decision making was
the country of Costa Rica which has gone
from predominantly deforestation to
reforestation
[Music]
the Costa Rica Now by most metrics has
the highest human development index is
the most prosperous and developed off
the countries of its neighborhood
[Music]
the GDP is neither are necessary nor a
sufficient indicator of human well-being
let alone the well-being of nature that
could sustain human well-being over time
rethinking the fundamental structure of
what's a good economy a good Nation a
good life is is a fundamental part of
what we need to do there's not one
Silver Bullet here but I think this
approach of Valor nature is an important
one
in some ways it is like that discussion
between idealists and pragmatists some
people feel we should not be putting a
price on nature then ethically it's not
right to do it all of us have that
idealist part in us but we also had to
be entirely pragmatic we need a
blueprint for nature that says these
parts of the globe are the most
important for nature and we absolutely
must protect them putting a price on
nature is one way to Value it is not the
only way to Value nature and so if we
just recognize that monetary evaluation
is but one of a suite of ways that would
go a long way
foreign
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video